sie behalten den Überblick im Chaos
damit solche Bilder nie wieder vorkommen
[Musik]
sie gehören zu Elite der deutschen
Polizeieinheiten
sie setzen ihr Leben ein um uns zu
schützen die Sky Marshalls die
flugsicherheitsbegleiter der
Bundespolizei eine Einheit so geheim
dass wir ihre Gesichter nicht zeigen
dürfen nein eleven war der erste
Anschlag wo wir damit konfrontiert waren
dass man ein Flugzeug als Waffe benutzt
als Waffe gegen Menschen um einen
Massenmord zu produzieren
und haben uns die Bilder natürlich immer
und immer wieder angesehen und er man
hat sie noch alle im Kopf und es macht
dann immer noch wahllos
deswegen müssen wir in der heutigen Zeit
weiterhin damit rechnen dass jederzeit
einen Anschlag auf einen Luftfahrzeug in
einem solchen Ausmaße wieder stattfinden
kann
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott ich wollte diese Bilder
sehe dann denke ich mir
solange ich auf dem Flugzeug bin solange
ich an Bord bin wird das nicht mehr
passieren
[Musik]
man kann nicht erkennen ob wir an Bord
sind wenn man erkennt dass wir an Bord
sind hat man in der Regel falsch
geschätzt oder wir haben schlecht
gearbeitet das sollte aber nicht
vorkommen
wird die Einheit gegründet bis heute ist
sie aber kaum bekannt ich bin die erste
Reporterin die auf dem geheimen
Übungsgelände drehen darf und ich kann
sogar mitmachen
[Musik]
gesehen haben haben Sie einen kleinen
Einblick gehabt wie wir versuchen uns
auf den Einsatz vorzubereiten es umfasst
natürlich noch ein weitaus größeres
Spektrum
schusswaffenabwehr Messerabwehr und
andere Sachen die uns noch gefährlich
sein können kann ich sagen welchen
Partner möchten Sie denn gerne mal
miterleben alles
in Ordnung
[Musik]
es fängt leicht an ein paar liegestütze
ein kleines aufwärm drehen
doch schnell wird es ernst
[Musik]
nach einer halben Stunde auf der Matte
ist es klar meine zwei Jahre in der
israelischen Armee sind schon lange her
nein nein nein
der grobe Bewegungsablauf passt und
alles andere ist viel Zeit im Training
noch mal oh ehrgeizig
als Sky Marshall muss man an Bord aber
nicht nur kämpfen können sondern im
Ernstfall auch präzise und Ziele sicher
schießen die Treffen wirklich jedes Mal
[Musik]
als ich es dann selbst versuche singt
die Erfolgsquote
[Musik]
das Korn muss zwischen die Kippen okay
ich mach's
Finger raus aus dem Abzug alles klar
ist ein bisschen gesprungen
leider treffen nur zwei von fünf Kugeln
das Ziel die ersten zwei waren doch
relativ okay die waren völlig okay
solange das alles noch im gelb ist also
schick ist es schwieriger im Flugzeug zu
schießen als was
eine schöne Bahn wir haben kein
Hindernisse aber eine Flugzeug ist
entsprechend sehr sehr Einsatzraum sehr
schwieriger Einsatzraum und da muss
natürlich jeder Schuss sitzen damit
keine Fehler erlaubt sind zwar nicht auf
jedem deutschen Flug dabei aber immer
dann wenn Sie der Meinung sind dass eine
Gefahr bestehen könnte wir versuchen
natürlich nach einem gewissen
Zufallsprinzip unberechenbar zu sein
niemand soll erahnen können wann wir auf
einem Flugzeug sind
aber man soll immer mit uns rechnen
können da bedienen wir uns mehrere
Informationen einmal von
Nachrichtendiensten einmal von Polizei
hier Aufklärung aber natürlich auch
gegen politische lagen in verschiedenen
Ländern
keine Einzelkämpfer sondern arbeiten im
Team ihr Job ist anstrengen und selbst
wenn alles gut geht sehr gefährlich in
ihre Ausbildung trainieren Sie unzählige
gefahrenszenarien Terrorismus hat viele
Gesichter
[Musik]
boring
hat die Anschnallzeichen ausgeschaut
[Musik]
ich weiß Ihnen was kommt aber ich weiß
halt nicht was
davon
in terroristischen
Anschlägen oder ähnlichen Anschlägen
Bedrohungslagen etc werden mir mit einer
solchen Intensität agieren das mit den
Angriff unmissverständlich und
konsequent sofort beenden und da wird
man auch ganz klar erkennen dass hier
die Polizei an Bord ist
[Musik]
Ende
okay okay
unerwartet ist auch eine Frau im
Einsatztraining zu sehen Nadel heißt sie
mit Spitznamen Polizei legen Sie die
Hände auf den Kopf
sie ist einer der wenigen Frauen in
Deutschland die in eine Spezialeinheit
der Bundespolizei kämpft ich glaube das
Bild in einer Sondereinheit zu arbeiten
ist man muss groß und stark sein und
männlich und so ein richtiger Brecher
sein und ja wie man sehen kann dem ist
halt nicht so
[Musik]
natürlich ist jeder Sky Marshall erst
einmal Polizist in die Spezialeinheit
aber kommt nur wer ausgewählt wird die
drei monatige Ausbildung ist vor allem
gleich
frauenrabatt gibt es hier nicht also man
hat schon das Gefühl man ist immer noch
im Fokus und muss mehr leisten um die
Anerkennung zu kriegen das ist schon so
aber man bekommt auch die Anerkennung
also man muss sich nicht kleiner machen
als man ist ähm die Jungs akzeptieren
halt vorher jüngst hat mir im letzten
eignungsauswahl Verfahren eine sehr
junge Beamtin die in so einem Trainer
dermaßen verprügelt hat wie wir das so
noch nicht erlebt haben und daraufhin
bin ich zu der Dame gegangen und habe
gefragt was treiben sie für eine
Kampfsportart
daraufhin kam die ganz
leichte Antwort gar keine ich bin
einfach die jüngste Schwester von
insgesamt vier Geschwistern und habe
drei Brüder und ich komme vom Dorf ich
muss mich durchsetzen und das war
einfach ein Moment wo wir gesagt haben
das ist die richtige Frau für unsere
Tätigkeit sie sind eine echte
überraschungskarte vor die Besatzungen
Bord aber auch für potentieller
theoristen es fühlt sich sehr gut an die
überraschungskarte zu sein es ist sehr
lustig die Kuh macht sich oft ein Spaß
draus
im Flieger doch herauszufinden ob Skype
er macht als ein Bord sind und wie viele
und wo die sitzen und dann ähm ja Tigern
die schön durch die Gänge und laufen bei
mir vorbei und man sieht richtig die
Blicke schweißen und alle Sitze aber es
hat mich keiner auf dem Schirm
[Musik]
im Chaos den Überblick zu behalten dafür
trainieren diese Männer und Frauen wo
ist denn jetzt der Täter hier vorne
ist schon
sehr gut
wir fliegen grundsätzlich dorthin mit wo
deutsche Fluggesellschaften hinfliegen
und so lange diese fliegen fliegen wir
auch an Bord mit in diese Flugzeuge zu
beschützen
[Musik]
Kai Marsches werden alles machen sogar
ihr Leben riskieren damit ein Anschlag
wie nein Leveln nie wieder passieren
kann
[Musik]